thank you kendall all right april was
autism awareness month and findlay
automotive group
granted a gift to a special local
organization take a look
you know findlay automotive group is all
about cars and communities so we're here
at findlay toyota
and tyler corder of course is here ready
to do something really special for the
community
why are you wearing blue today so these
blue shirts are uh
in recognition of last month april was
autism awareness month so we
decked our staff out i had him wearing
these blue shirts to recognize that
and here at findlay toyota we were
raising money all month we were putting
in fifty dollars for every new car we
sold we were selling
puzzle pieces in our service department
and uh raising money all month
for uh one of our favorite charities
grant to gift autism foundation which is
a charity we've been supporting
for a number of years and we just wanted
to uh in recognition of autism awareness
month we want to present them with a
check so that's why we're here today
and we have with us sandy findlay
who is on the board of granite gift
autism foundation and of course john
barr
our general manager here at findlay
toyota and we have peter
uh who is with the grand gift autism
foundation and uh
wanted to present this check for 30 000
today
for money we raised last month for
autism awareness that is awesome a
little round of applause that is so
great and we're going to talk to peter
now about this amazing guest peter how
are you feeling
uh this is amazing i mean obviously a
big thank you to tyler
to john of course to sandy who has
tyler's headsets on our board
this money is going to go to great use
we use it for staffing and for services
at granite gift autism foundation as
well as the ackermann center yeah and
now tell us a little bit more about
granite granite gift autism
happy too people would be really
surprised to learn that one in 54 kids
are diagnosed on the autism spectrum and
what's even more shocking is that here
in town a city is big and as vibrant as
ours here in las vegas
we simply lack the services to help
people get diagnosed and then the
services that they need beyond that so
granted gift autism foundation helps the
ackermann center provide those services
and this money is going to go to
additional staffing so we can simply
help more families
that's amazing well i'm so happy for you
guys thank you tyler philly automotive
group for doing so much for the
community thank you for everything that
you're doing
for our community as well how can people
help you guys out beyond this check
donations are much needed obviously
again this is towards uh
you know all the services that we're
trying to provide in the community i can
go to our website please
grant the gift autism foundation uh and
we would welcome all your donations and
your help all right thank you peter
congratulations thank you
thank you philly automotive to find more
information on the grant
gift autism foundation just call
702-564-2453